all right guys
bang bang i've got mitch here with me
thank you so much for doing this sir
thanks thanks a lot for sure let's just
jump right into your background you've
had this great business and investing
career
but a lot of people probably aren't
familiar with how you got started where
did you grow up and how did you get into
business
yeah thanks a lot well i mean we'll go
backwards i'm 56 years old today so
i grew up in montreal in canada i live
there now because there's been a lot of
stops in between but um
i went to college in montreal to mcgill
university i went to law school at the
university of ottawa
and i practiced law for for nine years
and i sort of got very lucky i was
i was a lawyer in the early 90s so 96 97
the internet starts
and i read an article by roxy roxborough
talking about a european sports book on
the internet
that um i thought was really interesting
i ripped out the article it was an
actual real physical world article in
international gaming and wagering
business magazine
um and i found the owner of that company
in austria and i called him and i said i
wanted
i want to figure out some way we could
do business together because i see that
you know
you're trying to do business over the
internet in gaming i was a gaming lawyer
representing
igt caesar's at the time uh even though
i
later on hooked up with caesars it was
unrelated so i was a gaming way or
gaming related law gaming was exploding
in the 90s uh every state and every
province was getting casinos
um but i saw the internet i read this
article by roxy
and um when i finally spoke to the owner
of this
this sports book what he really needed
was payment processing
and so i called a friend of mine in
montreal who was a
really well-known business uh well
business couple two guys
and um they owned an internet service
provider
and they i told listen i need to find a
way to process payments for this
sportsbook in austria
at the same time i offered him my
services to help him get licensed in
antigua which i did
and so these two guys started a little
payment processing business
in the back of their service provider
and a few years later i left my law
practice and joined them
uh the company got bought by dell canada
we got tons of stock in this
e-commerce uh subsidiary of bell
we did very well we spun out the
payments business we created our own
public company
we grew it we sold it to a nasdaq
company it grew again
um i later left it to run party gaming
but this payment processing company
uh today is called paysafe and it's got
an 11 billion dollar market cap
um so the guys who started it myself and
these two other guys
it's been through a couple of different
um i guess you know versions of itself
but that business that started by
processing the sports book
payments in and payments out of an
austrian sports book in 1997
is today the 11 billion dollar uh
paysafe that just went public in a space
by uh bill foley the owner of the las
vegas knights
so i got my start as a lawyer gaming
lawyer got into payment processing
got into the internet quite early i was
offered the job as the ceo of party
poker party gaming at the time it was a
10 billion dollar company i moved to
gibraltar with my family
i ran that business for two years during
those two years
the unlawful internet gaming act packed
and
passed in 2006 in america i turned off
the us
part of our business which took the
business from a 10 billion market cap to
a 2 billion
market cap i learned a lot we recovered
very well
the stock did well the shareholders did
well notwithstanding having to turn off
a substantial amount of the business
and um i met mark rowan one of the
founders of apollo
and he and david bonderman who co-owned
in their firms tpg and apollo they
co-owned caesars
which was 50 casino properties around
the united states and elsewhere
and they asked me if i was interested in
starting a digital uh subsidiary
of caesars and owning the world series
of poker so i'll stop now but
that's sort of the the start of my
career as a lawyer
and then payment processing and gaming
was in my life
um until party gaming when i left party
gaming and i i did start this subsidiary
of caesars and
i guess the rest will talk about yeah so
when you go to start that
subsidiary what's so fascinating to me
is you essentially go from
practicing law around gaming to running
a company
and probably dealing with one of the
most catastrophic things that could
happen in terms of having shut off the
us business
and then really kind of jumping full in
to a u.s based business right and kind
of saying
we're gonna go do digital gaming what
was so exciting about
kind of coming to the us to do this was
it
you know bonderman and apollo and kind
of the players was it the opportunity
uh was it just you were gonna get uh
opportunity to kind of
build a skill set and experience like
what really drove you to say yes to it
you know i think number one i felt that
i had made the money
that was gonna make me happy and
comfortable for the rest of my life and
so i wasn't
going to be driven driven by by money i
loved the idea of working with bonderman
and rowan and apollo and tpg
and the caesars brand always resonated
with me because i was someone who knew a
lot about gaming
and knew a lot about gaming law and so
to be able to be sort of wrapped in the
caesar's palace brand and the planet
hollywood brand
and the world series of poker brand i
thought that was a great opportunity for
me
we thought that poker would become legal
in the united states we'd own the world
series of poker
and we would make a lot of money for our
shareholder for our stakeholders and our
shareholders
uh that turned out to not be the case
but um i think your first
intuition is right that i saw this
opportunity to to be with around
bonderman and rowan and this group gary
loveman who was the ceo at the time and
i remember that
when i started working there um i went
to bonnerman and rowan both
separately and i told them what i really
want is that if i'm successful here
so 2008 if i'm successful here um i'd
like to be in your ecosystem
afterwards i'd like to be able to invest
with you i'd like to sit on boards
and they both said that sounds like a
good idea i don't know at the time if
they were
you know thinking that this was serious
or not but as it turns out it's 12 years
later and that's what i do
so i i saw the opportunity to be around
people that i thought
could really help me in my life if i and
i could help them as well but
to be around them it was being around
winners actually you know it's kind of
like if i could you know play for the
golden state warriors two years ago that
would be
you know that would be awesome so i felt
like you know i was maybe the last man
on the bench but i was playing on a
great team and i was happy to be there
yeah and in terms of as you get that
business started kind of tell us the
story of starting it
all the way to uh to when you decide to
leave yeah what happened was you know
from from 2009 to 2010
we were very hopeful that we would get
legalized online poker
we ran into sheldon adelson who didn't
want internet
poker and he had a lot of you know the
way the u.s
political system works i think you know
it very very well but these super pacs
are pretty powerful
um and you know i believe that sheldon
made sure that internet poker didn't
become
legal because he wasn't ready for it
didn't understand it and didn't want it
um and so once we realized that we
realized this i hate to use the word
pivot but we knew we had to pivot
because i had a meeting in december 2010
with my management team
i said guys listen i don't think that
you are going to become wealthy
running the world series of poker and if
we don't find something else you're all
going to look for something else
because look it's the wild west the
world is young you guys are young guys
um and so we started looking around and
we saw zenga poker
and we saw a farm villain and we said
hey you know what
why would xenga poker not want to be you
know involved with the world series of
poker and
add that brand to their to their social
game at the time it was mostly on
facebook it wasn't a mobile game
and so we went down we finally got a
meeting with them they didn't take us
that seriously we met with mark pinkis
he didn't take us seriously
he might say differently today but he
didn't take us that seriously and um
he didn't he didn't really want to do
much with us and so as we left the
meeting with zenga
in san francisco we said okay now we've
got to do it ourselves now i had um
i had a lot of experience in israel i
speak hebrew i lived in israel i said
listen israel is a great
hub of game development
let's try to find something there and lo
and behold
a friend of mine asked me if i had heard
of a certain company which i had not
the company was doing run rate of about
10 million of ebitda with 13 employees
in an apartment in tel aviv
i flew to tel aviv sat in the apartment
i met with the guys i fell in love with
them
and went back to the board at caesars
you know an elder
elderly an older board you know a board
of bonderman's and
people of his generation and explain to
them i want to buy this
social games company where people are
playing games just for fun and they'll
buy coins just to add
you know to the experience but they
don't have any chance to redeem them or
win anything
and i want to pay a hundred million
dollars for this business which was ten
times even though
and actually you know i could make the
story sound more exciting but they said
go ahead and do it
and we went and we bought that company
and that company
has has done spectacularly well um
four and a half years later we sold it
to a consortium in china including jack
ma's
uh family office for 4.4 billion dollars
and now it's four years later they've um
they've um uh they've issued their s1
and they'll be public in two weeks at
about an 11 billion dollar market cap so
bought it for 100 sold it for 4.4 same
management team stayed there i didn't i
stayed at caesars to to finish uh
you know a couple of projects i was
working on and those guys have done
um incredibly well and i'm very proud of
them so platika will be public
in new york in the third week in january
probably around 11 12 billion dollar
market cap so a really amazing story
um and the money that caesar's uh earned
from that sale they used to settle with
the creditors of caesar's parent company
which was in in restructuring at the
time so it's a really good story for
uh for just about everybody the
creditors at caesars the shareholders
stakeholders my management team myself
and now once again uh the management
team and founders of platika
yeah it's an amazing story and so
obviously you kind of continued to do
the work at caesars eventually
you leave and you now do a whole bunch
of stuff
investing you sit on a couple of boards
i've really enjoyed getting to know you
let's maybe talk a little bit about the
board of director positions that you
hold
two of those are rackspace and
shutterfly this year
or really 2020 has not been the most fun
year to be running businesses that
potentially could be impacted by a
global pandemic government
mandated shutdowns talk us just through
as a experienced board member who's
previously run pretty large companies
and had a lot of success
what were those conversations like over
the last year with executives
um and kind of what were the things that
you were thinking about or you were
really hoping that executives were
paying attention to at some of these
larger companies yeah well you know
first of all
there's a great amount of luck here
right so
um i'll start with the worst experience
i also helped tpg by cirque du soleil
and i was the chairman of surface la and
i had a
you know multi-million dollar investment
in la uh and the circ
is now 300 days into zero revenue so
from a business that generated close to
two billion dollars of revenue it's been
at zero
for 300 days it went into restructuring
it's now owned by
by its lenders so those conversations
were
were very very difficult because we
couldn't figure out a way
that you could actually sustain yourself
at zero revenue
um and service the debt so you know you
always
you always will will have a contingency
plan what if we lose 20
of our revenue what if we lose 30 of our
revenue what if we're shut down for a
month
or two it's very difficult to to foresee
a situation and be prepared for a
situation where you have 6 000 employees
um and you're out of business i think
the circle be out of business for a year
and a half
so that was a you know a really
unfortunate situation of course you know
i did learn a lot
we made some decisions but there were
none that we could have made that would
have
made it into a success um and that's
that's what i'm talking about when i
talk about good luck bad luck you know
if this would have been an internet
virus and not a human virus
and google was down for a year and a
half and all the internet cloud
companies were down for a year and a
half well live entertainment would be
thriving
and the internet wouldn't be so that was
on the negative side on the positive
side of course i'm in rackspace a cloud
services business
you know couldn't be better um had the
best year in the history of rackspace
went public again so we took it private
in 2015 took it public again about two
months ago
um have a phenomenal ceo and
you know the decisions there were if we
need to invest in the business
to accelerate the growth let's do that
let's not just sit back
because the cloud is growing and try to
have the highest margins possible with
you know with short-sightedness let's
have
let's have real foresight let's make
sure that we're here
after the pandemic as a high-growth
cloud services company
and kevin jones who's the ceo is is
doing a great job
uh in the case of shutterfly we weren't
exactly sure how the
you know how we were going to be
impacted on the one hand we have a
business
um where we're the largest uh procurer
taker of of high school graduation and
uh college graduation and church photos
um with a company called life touch so
of course
there were hardly any school photos but
at the same time
uh the amount the the the volume
of photo books and other merchandise
that that we sell through shutterfly
uh has really been astounding so we've
had a great year
um in in shutterfly people are stuck at
home
you know the average person i don't know
this i'm making the number up but the
average person that i know
okay so if i ask you how many photos are
in your phone right now the number is
probably like 10
000 a lot of people have 20 000 most
people have 2
000 um and they're just disorganized and
so people have had a lot of time
um and we've seen that because they've
taken and used that time
to upload photos and create photo albums
mugs pillows
uh calendars um christmas cards um
etc so you know i think that it's it's
more a matter of luck than than
decisioning because at shutterfly and
rackspace we didn't have to pivot
um at at circus la we couldn't pivot
and again luck struck us at the seattle
kraken where i'm on the executive
board of the kraken and in the ownership
group with david bonderman and jerry
bruckheimer and andy jassy
um and i guess you could say we've
gotten lucky we start
in october 2021 and so we haven't had to
go through this
partial season no fans uh we launched
our team name we launched the team logo
we launched our merchandise very
successfully we're second in sales only
the tampa bay lightning because they won
the cup
um and then we'll have the draft in july
and uh
two days later we'll have the nhl uh
entry draft
so um you know i think i think you have
to have a really strong board in all of
these situations
and i think you have to play to your
strengths and um you know i said like i
said i've been in more lucky situations
during during the pandemic than not and
at the same time you have to have a lot
of empathy
because the whole world's not in the
cloud the whole world is not uh chamath
and david sachs and elon musk
and pomp and the whole world is not in
bitcoin and blockchain
um you know the world is construction
workers restaurant owners hotel workers
uh service people stuck at home uh
school teachers
so um yeah i think it's just been a very
interesting
interesting time not only as a board
member investor but just as a you know
as a human being
for sure we're going to talk about
bitcoin in a second but before we get to
that uh
you've been around the same people for a
decade plus at this point and
you've mentioned some of their names now
talk a little bit just about
how important it was for you and for
your career development kind of the
success that you've had
to not only one surround yourself with
people who
you admired you found successful or kind
of the winners that you described
but also too to do it for a long period
of time so not just hey let's work on
one thing but to continuously work with
the same people over and over and over
again over a decade
like why do you feel like that's been so
important to your success
you know first of all i'm watching you
and i see um a lot of myself in in you
or you and me
we haven't known each other for long but
i see that you you do a couple of things
number one
you value the networking without
seeking to benefit necessarily from the
network even though you know you will
if you meet jim crane or jim cramer and
immediate elon musk
at some point that will probably it
probably will be good for you but you
don't have this
you know preconceived notion of how am i
going to leverage my relationship with
elon musk or or chamoth or whoever um
i think that's important and the second
thing that i find that you do that i
think is important is that
you've taken a couple of areas of
business and you know them as well or
better than anybody else
so if you value relationships and you
don't
seek to benefit from them necessarily
and so they're authentic
i think my relationship with vonderman's
authentic with dan gilbert's authentic
with mark rowan it's authentic they
happen to be the the billionaires
i have lots of relationships with people
who you know are in the fourth level of
management in companies and have been
with me since 1999 or 2003
um and i value their friendships and
their relationships and their loyalty
um and we've figured out a way most of
the time to actually make money and have
success together
and we figure out a way to deal with uh
failures disappointments
and and and the like um and i feel like
you know i've tried to know
as much as i can about the things that
i'm i'm involved with today it's a bit
more difficult because i don't know more
about digital photography uploading than
the people who work at shutterfly and i
certainly don't know more about you know
service cloud services business as the
people at rackspace
but um i think it's important when i was
the ceo of companies
you know that i had that i had the
knowledge
and the trust of the people who work for
me that i was working at least as hard
as they were
and so i feel that the barnums and
rowans and gilberts and and loveman's
and
and the like they recognize my work
ethic and hopefully if they find me
authentic
and we found interesting fun ways to
work together you know i once said to
bonderman
um i said and jim coulter's another one
who i just adore and devesh macan at
iconic
who manage a large amount of our of our
family assets today
um i said to bonderman one day said you
know david
you're worth four or five billion
dollars why are you and i making
investments where you know we're each
investing a million dollars or even
half a million dollars and his answer
was the most beautiful answer ever he
was
i just want to be in interesting deals
with people i want to be in deals with
and so that told me everything you know
he doesn't have to write a 20 million
dollar check to make it exciting just
wants to be in an exciting business with
people that he likes if it's a half a
million or
25 million or 150 million um he just
wants to be there and that's how i feel
so if my check is fifty thousand five
hundred thousand a million five million
i wanna be there with the people that
are in it and um
and and we share kind of that same those
same values
yeah that's a great way to look at it um
before we talk about bitcoin uh you
mentioned iconic
uh and a number of the investments
you've made talk through a little bit
just how you think uh philosophically
about managing your wealth
uh and investing in general you
obviously trust the folks at iconic
and then you do some of the direct
investing like what is there a certain
philosophy
or approach or framework that you use
when you think about how do i actually
invest the money that i have
well first of all um i feel like i'm
surrounded by people
who know much more than i do
about many of the investments that i
have and so
i'm better off to rely on iconic due
diligence
in getting into snowflake and then
participating in the cone best of
snowflake
so i'm not smart in having
a big you know investment in snowflake
i'm lucky to have
a big investment in snowflake i'm smart
to
trust iconic i'm lucky to be in the
ecosystem of iconic iconic's a big
shared family office and they manage a
lot of mark zuckerberg shadow sandburg
dorsey
bonderman um mattel so
you know i always say like i'm the
little guy in that office and i'm super
happy to be it's it's fine
um and then i invest in then i have a
second basket of investments where
the people i trust are making
investments and they feel and i feel
that i can add value to the management
team
so i'll make a you know a multi-million
dollar investment
rackspace shutterfly um i've done that
in a number of businesses whether it's
circus la or
long van wolford and i'll sit on the
board
and i'll i'll help management usually
they're businesses that i'm interested
in
um so i'm happy to make the investment i
want to sit on the board
um i want to help management i want to
get deeply involved in
in their success and if if there are
failures along the way then you know
i'll help them through those if i help
cause them then i'll help them find ways
to get out of them
but um so generally speaking and now i'm
making a number of smaller investments
and things that just interest me that i
don't know how they're gonna turn out
um you know i'm invested in a company
that's uh seeking to prolong the life of
dogs
and i think that's really cool and i
think that the woman who runs it is
is really really great and so i made a
small investment there
um i'll make investments in things that
i don't know much about but i find
interesting
either socially interesting you know i'm
no longer going to invest in oil and i
have lots of big investments in oil so i
want to invest in oil i won't invest in
gun manufacturers i want to invest
obviously in coal i don't know that many
people that i know are investing in coal
today but
um try to be a bit socially conscious
and try to find things that interest me
you know my investment in
in london and wilford uh are because i
love fashion
um but i do think that we'll get a good
return on the investment and i
i brought paris hilton and steve aoki
along with me and they love fashion so
you know hopefully we'll make something
out of it so
good people around me that you know i
really trust
then there are the good people that i'm
associated with like apollo tpg and
fosun
where they're doing great due diligence
for the most part
and you know they have so many
investments that there are some that are
appealing to me
and where i can add value and sit on the
board and that's really exciting for me
and so
those are the kinds of things that i'm
obviously the hockey team i mean
wonderment asking me if i wanted to be
part of the ownership group yes i mean
that's a canadian kid's dream right
i love that part uh let's talk about
bitcoins that's how you and i uh got
connected we've done a couple of calls
um and i think i've been really
impressed with just uh your intellectual
curiosity
uh your open-mindedness and really the
reason why we wanted to record this was
you have a lot of questions that many
people that you
spend all day with whether they're
executives or investors
have but also you've got a very unique
view in that
you've built a lot of great businesses
or been in investing in great businesses
and so
you have a level of resources that maybe
the everyday person doesn't have which
means that you have certain questions or
concerns
uh or a perspective or thought process
that again you know kind of the average
person doesn't and so
let's just start maybe kind of with like
how you
currently see bitcoin and maybe some of
the considerations as you're thinking
through it and then we can get into the
questions that you have
okay so let me start with the way we met
because
it it will dovetail into my questions
about bitcoin
i have two sons 25 and 20. my 20 year
old son
um you know he sees that i'm involved
with the kraken and he sees that i'm
involved with long vein
and he's been following the influencer
trend
on tick tock and instagram and he's been
following you
and he felt and he didn't tell me this
first but he felt that we needed to meet
and then that
he felt that he wanted to see whether we
could do something with you for long
vein or for the kraken with influencers
and the reason i bring that up is
because um bitcoin's a bit like that
right there's a generational gap i'm 56
there's a generation gap between what's
going on on tick tock if tick tock's
really
making 17 times more even than instagram
how many people know that
um there's a generation gap also in in
bitcoin doesn't mean there's not a lot
of older guys in bitcoin and women there
are
but there's a bit of a generation gap in
blockchain and bitcoin
and so i find that i've sort of passed
through a couple of phases
the phase of you know bitcoin that's
[ __ ]
bitcoin um it's a bubble uh
bitcoin um nobody understands it
right and then i passed it to the point
where i said wait a minute
really smart people i know um are
really engaged in bitcoin okay leave
aside your posts every day reminding all
of us who don't own bitcoin that it's up
another thousand every 15 minutes leave
that aside for a minute
but really smart friends of mine are in
bitcoin because they
feel they understand it all right and
now there are guys like me
who are saying okay pomp i have access
to you thank you for that access
i want to use it for you to explain
bitcoin to me
um i have a bank account and i have a
brokerage account
and in that brokerage account i own
shares and a number of public
uh equities and in that brokerage
account
um i have two or three different
currencies
and i want to put a million or two
million dollars of bitcoin into that
account well you can't
so i start by asking you the question um
you know around
if i wanted to buy them and i did ask
you this question i want to buy a
million or two million dollars of
bitcoin
how do i get comfortable where i'm
sending that money because it's not
going to be wells fargo it's not credit
swiss it's not [ __ ]
how do i get comfortable where i'm
sending that money how do i get
comfortable
that what i'm getting in return is two
million dollars worth of bitcoin
that i can create liquidity with when i
need to
okay and that i can rely on it being in
a safe secure place that i'll always be
able to turn to it
whatever the value is maybe maybe the
price goes down maybe it goes up
so the first question i think it's it's
it's one of the first questions
is how do you get me comfortable around
that idea that i can't just
buy it like i buy google stock yeah
so and you know we're cheating a little
bit because this question we've talked
at length about but i think the first
thing is
uh people get really comfortable when
they hear um especially when they've got
large resources fidelities in the game
or jp morgan's in the game goldman sachs
is getting in the game right like okay
those are brands that
they're from the legacy world whether
i'm a customer or
uh or not i know them i have friends
that work there i know people who use
them
and uh i have some level of trust simply
because it's a brand that i understand
and if they're doing it there must be
some level of regulatory compliance
security uh transparency reporting etc
um and i think that just that alone gets
people to say oh okay like maybe there
is a path maybe i'll use fidelity for
example or maybe i won't but at least i
know that there is a path that
matches uh the way that i normally do
things but to your point i can't go do
it in my citibank account
you know or or one of the other accounts
you mentioned the
second component of this is there's a
lot of crypto native
uh or bitcoin native solutions so these
are usually the exchanges or custody
providers
they tend to be names that uh the
average
wealthy person or investor has not heard
before before they start looking so this
is
you know coinbase gemini blockfi um
and a whole bunch of others uh but what
you do quickly realize is wait a second
coinbase has 35 million registered users
right they've got 25 plus
billion dollars of assets on their
platform like these are numbers that
uh show one uh sustainability so they've
been around for you know many years
uh two they're backed by um kind of tier
one venture capitalists many people
you've co-invested with or that you know
uh and then three is just the kind of
lindy effect of like the longer it's
around and the more assets that get put
there and the more people who use it
the more people just have have comfort
and whether they should or not that's
just a natural human
psychological uh kind of component right
you just get comfortable with something
that is popular
uh and so i think that once people start
to understand
okay i have options right i have legacy
options and i have these kind of new
uh bitcoin native or crypto native
options then it's really just like
what do i want to accomplish right so
for somebody like you
you you'll be the first one to say like
you're not a day trader you're not going
to go sit and try to time big bitcoins
market and buy and sell multiple times a
day
so what you basically want to do is you
want to think of it from an asset
allocation standpoint
i'm going to put you know let's call two
million dollars into bitcoin and i'm
basically going to park it there
and sure i'll watch the price because
it's fun and exciting but like
i'm not going to make any investment
decisions based on if bitcoin's at 32 33
or 34
000 i'm pretty much putting an
allocation and i'm going to watch what
happens
and so when that occurs i think really
where people kind of focus
is like the on-ramp to bitcoin uh is
somewhat uh commoditized meaning that
um you can go and use the legacy options
or you can use the bitcoin native
options
but really where the differentiation
comes is around custody
so do you want to self-custody asset or
do you want somebody else to custody it
for you
and i think that's the the part of the
conversation where uh one there's a lack
of education but also two there's
uh frankly fear right you know how many
times have you read something that like
bitcoin got hacked
right well bitcoin didn't get hacked uh
an exchange got hacked the custody
provider got hacked whatever
and so i think that what is probably not
as well understood in the bitcoin
community
is for you right it sounds crazy but
like a two million dollar investment
is material but it's also not material
right in the sense of if you're used to
doing
very large deals with your money or
other people's money it's
enough for you to pay attention but it's
also not enough where you say you know
what i'm gonna really trust myself to go
self-custody this i'm gonna put it on
uh some sort of hardware wallet and i'm
gonna put it in the safe in my house or
something like that
and so your use case is very very
different than
you know somebody who's kind of in the
hardcore bitcoin community
now people will debate should you
self-custody should you not
we'll put that debate aside it just
comes down to where do you have
confidence because this allocation is
important but it's not the most
important thing it's not the most
concentrated part of your portfolio
and so where i think people end up on
this is fidelity coinbase
gemini blockfi um you know jp morgan
goldman sachs like they'll all come up
with their thing
um or the next bucket is they'll
start using something like grayscale or
bitwise
for these kind of uh etf-like structures
so they're trust structures but there's
a public ticker
and so when you get in that world all of
a sudden you say okay
12 months from now if we have this
conversation you're going to be able to
buy it in your citibank account
right how it gets there what are the
processes talk about fidelity for a
minute
so if my mom has a fidelity account and
she has a million dollars in
can she can she buy a hundred thousand
dollars of bitcoin in that account
yeah so uh the folks at fidelity are
going to be all over me because i always
get this wrong
they they move so quickly that it's
constantly changing my understanding of
where they are right now is basically if
you're a high net worth individual or an
institution
uh you've got kind of a private client
type relationship
uh they will help you buy bitcoin they
will help you store bitcoin
um and i believe that they've announced
publicly uh they now will also give
loans against your bitcoin collateral
via partnership with blockchain
so but if you believe that in the next
three years you'll be able to click a
button and buy
bitcoin in your fidelity account in the
next five years
that should be the path to um
you know the gen pop buying bitcoin
not yes significant population well so
and this is what's pretty crazy right
is as i've kind of unpacked this more
and more
i've been fascinated to understand some
of the nuances around what like you know
the general population so when you
really think about in the united states
i know the numbers pretty well
uh about 45 of americans hold no
investable assets
right i mean just like no stocks no
bonds no um
you know and anything those people
actually
are very quickly getting caught up into
the investing world you have
covid shut down all sports so now they
got day trading stuff going on the robin
hoods the cash apps of the world
fractional shares crypto becomes a
really big thing
it's fun it's exciting it's got the
promise of you can become rich like all
it pulls people into it
and so i think that that like bottom you
know 45
or so of the population generally is
less educated has less resources
but now is starting to show a desire and
so some of that will change they'll get
more educated and hopefully will be able
to buy investing
kind of improve their financial life
then there is let's call it kind of
another 45 to 50 percent that's you know
the middle to the upper end of the
spectrum
uh these are folks who are uh into
investing they're somewhat sophisticated
they've got some you know level of
resources and also
they've got the persistence to go sign
up for coinbase or gemini or blockfire
or whatever
so they're willing to put their
information in for kycaml they're gonna
you know open a second account they're
going to go check it they're going to
make sure it's secure
like they want the exposure they
understand the value proposition
and their desire is large enough that
they'll actually go
do it the third group is let's call it
the top one to five percent
of americans up until maybe two years
ago
most of those people were sitting this
out it was too small it didn't make
sense a lot of the things that you said
right i don't understand it it's a
bubble you know all of those things
uh were that was the talking narrative
that's all shipped in the last 18 months
and so
i think those are the folks that uh
they're used to one of two things
either buying directly in that fidelity
account right and kind of being able to
click a button
uh or two being able to make very large
multi-million dollar investments in
assets where uh they're an accredited
investor they sign some documents and
basically now they own something
and so the the idea of i'm gonna go open
an account on this thing called coinbase
and i'm basically gonna wire money into
it and then make a purchase
but i can't see my stocks next to it and
i can't in my stock account see my
bitcoin
that's like a foreign concept to them
and so i think that really what you're
seeing is almost the reverse
the very low retail kind of 45 bottom of
the socioeconomic latter
they came in then you got the next 45
and then finally
it's you're seeing the one to five
percent these are the paul tudor joneses
the stanley druckenmillers
like they're coming when they show up
they're not showing up trying to buy you
know 500
worth of bitcoin try to buy 500 million
dollars
exactly so i think that's where you're
seeing the price kind of explode so i
agree
and i think i think i won't call it the
barrier to entry it's more the barrier
to
enter and once the barriers to enter are
are going to become more simple more
simplified i think that
you know that's when this thing will
really really take off so let's talk
about the supply for a minute okay
um i'll buy a stock tomorrow in a
company
and they may the next day issue 10
billion dollars of stock to buy another
company
right so i bought them they had 50
million shares outstanding next thing i
know they have a hundred million shares
outstanding
that might be fine right they may or may
not agree with the purchase but i don't
have enough stock to
vote so it doesn't really matter um so
people are caught up in this whole
supply
and supply and demand of of uh bitcoin
but yet we all own u.s dollars
where the supply is infinite and
definitely not
tapped we all own stock in public
companies where
the supply can go down by buying back
stock or up by issuing new stock
so let's talk about why people like me
uh need to understand better this supply
uh demand piece of bitcoin where there's
some fixed supply of
bitcoin yeah so on the supply side just
structurally it's a deflationary asset
meaning that there's 21 million uh over
time once we hit that 21 million cap
no more bitcoin will be created right
that is
uh determined by computer code that
computer code can only
be changed if more than 51 percent of
people agree
and obviously as more and more people
adopt this that went from you know at
one point
a couple hundred people had to agree to
now it's literally tens of millions and
one day will be hundreds of millions or
billions of people
that need to agree and so it's just
generally accepted and i personally
believe that will never happen it's too
much
kind of large-scale global coordination
needed to change uh that 21 million
uh uh cap so where does the voting take
place so
in in companies that i own shares in
they send proxies around
and we still in these sort of antiquated
way put x's in boxes and send it back so
how does it work in bitcoin yeah so
without getting really deep into
technical weeds uh that's not how it
happens um it is a
fairly technical process and so just if
you hold bitcoin
doesn't mean you get a vote right so
there's a whole mining process and
and proposals and and um kind of an
on-chain
much more technology-enabled uh voting
mechanism
compared to hey i mailed you i need to
know where you live right i made a piece
of paper you check off something email
it back
and so the other key piece to the
structure is that 21 million cap
but also the incoming daily supply
and what i mean by incoming daily supply
is um
as you described with the shares in a
company
it's set for a period of time until
there's a decision made to increase or
to buy back shares
right and those are fairly infrequent
decisions
uh and they create inflection points in
price uh
based on whether people agree or
disagree it becomes more attractive or
less attractive
well with bitcoin everything is
programmatic and that simply just means
that they literally wrote and code at
the creation of bitcoin
we're gonna have 21 million bitcoin and
then we are going to take those 21
million bitcoin
and we are gonna put them into
circulation on a predetermined
uh schedule and so it started out at
we're gonna put 50
bitcoin into circulation every 10
minutes and we're going to do that for
four years
after that four year period we will cut
that 50 in half
it's called the bitcoin having we'll go
down to 25 do that for four years
then we'll go down to uh 12 and a half
and then we'll do that for four years
and then we'll go down to where we are
today we're at 6.25 bitcoin
every 10 minutes so the key to this kind
of uh incoming daily supply is
over the last four years up until may
2020 there was
1800 bitcoin a day coming into this
circulating supply
well in may 2020 you got cut down to 900
bitcoin per day
and so just like there's a supply shock
in a company when there is either
buybacks or there is a large issuance
bitcoin has this kind of pre-programmed
supply shock
now the last thing i'll say about kind
of the structural supply side
is when you are trying to determine
market prices
you usually have two inputs right you've
got the supply and you've got demand and
those two things change
and you essentially are guessing or
estimating in an educated way
what's going to happen to the supply and
what's going to happen to demand
if supply stays constant and demand goes
up then we think price will go up or
vice versa
and and we kind of figure it out with
bitcoin
bitcoin is unique in that because it is
a programmatic
set supply schedule we have 100
certainty what is going to happen as
long as the code is not changed
and we can verify so i can literally
show you on the blockchain every day 900
bitcoin were created
here's where they went and so that kind
of certainty and predictability of a
programmatic monetary policy
is really unique because it then says if
we want to determine future price
movements
we simply have to model demand rather
than model uh supply and demand
and so i think that's one thing that uh
bitcoin has as an advantage over other
assets is
the supply side is held kind of
programmatically
and uh predictably and therefore the
focus then shifts just the demand side
not
the supply and demand side like in
traditional assets okay
great so i want to just jump back to a
preconceived notion that i had
which i no longer think is relevant but
it
drove my decision to not learn more
about bitcoin for a while
and that was the notion um people
i hate to sound like trump everyone's
saying people were saying
that people wanted bitcoin
as a means to pay for things anonymously
and i was thinking you know what
that doesn't seem like enough of a
market people aren't that
uncomfortable paying with paypal or
paying with their credit card or paying
with cash
that the world needs an anonymous
currency and that's what's going to
drive the value of it
now it turns out that that's not really
the narrative anymore that
people need an anonymous currency and
that the future of paying for things is
bitcoin it might be
but that's no longer the narrative so
what is the narrative
in terms of um you know if i buy stock
in google i think their earnings will
increase quarter over quarter for the
next several years if i buy
gold it's because you know i don't
understand gold that well but there is a
supply
of gold that's more physically um
verifiable to most people not to you but
to most people that don't have to code
for bitcoin they can see the gold supply
and understand the supply of the price
of gold
so what is it that's going to drive
especially since we now know that it's
going to become easier and easier to buy
bitcoin
so what's going to drive the value of
bitcoin
once we get to the point where everyone
can buy a bitcoin the way they can buy a
share of google
yeah so the beauty of narratives is uh
there's always multiple narratives of
any asset
and some of them are true some of them
are not and you as an investor basically
have to figure out which ones are which
right um and so google's a great example
you may buy it because you think
earnings are going to go up somebody
else may buy it because they think even
with earnings flat it's undervalued
today
and somebody else may buy it because
they think that google's the most
innovative company in the world they
don't care about the finances and they
just want to own
the tech or back the founder or whatever
right um and so with bitcoin
i i agree that early on there was this
um you know very big focus
on um you know what people called
anonymous but
essentially suit anonymous payments
right as oh you can use this anywhere
uh obviously that's super attractive to
uh criminals drug dealers money
launderers you know
that whole crowd and so venezuela you
know all that stuff
all of them and so one of the things
that's really interesting is uh
in the beginning people hadn't had a lot
of time to study bitcoin to study
technology adoption to study the way
that uh
currencies get uh kind of um you know
permeate throughout a society
now after 10 years there's a lot of
really really smart people paying
attention to this writing about it and
kind of analyzing it
and so given the information we have
today there's a couple of key data
points
one almost every great technology is
first adopted by the fringes of society
so beeper cell phones internet right
it's this constant
cat and mouse game between law
enforcement and bad actors and they're
constantly looking for new technology to
skirt law enforcement
so it's actually a positive sign uh if
you look at it from a technology
adoption standpoint
that those are the people who first
adopted bitcoin right because it's kind
of the natural progression
does it feel great from a society
standpoint when that's the narrative on
day one
but but it's actually a natural thing to
happen the second thing
is um that people say oh it is
electronic cash right it is a p2p
electronic cash right right written in
the white paper well that is true
but one of the key pieces to understand
about a
currency right if you go back and you
look at let's say gold is
you first have to have store of value
properties
before you can have medium of exchange
properties so real quick example of gold
is
gold served as this great store of value
for 5 000 years uh but it's hard to use
it's hard to carry around it's heavy
it's hard to break into you know
divisible pieces uh it's hard to kind of
measure
you know one ounce versus another
without a scale all those issues you
can't send it right across
borders um you know in the mail very
easily all that kind of stuff
but in order to solve that problem we
basically took gold and we said rather
than carry around the gold why don't we
put the gold in a safe
and we'll create paper claims on the
gold so literally the us dollar backed
by gold
and we'll just trade around this paper
claims much easier to use much easier to
divide much easier to
kind of count and really drive kind of
velocity of money or commerce
well eventually we said great those
dollars are awesome why don't we then
create electronic versions of them so
now we can just trade ones and zeros on
computers rather than have to carry
around the physical cash
and then we created credit and kind of
all these other layers on top of it and
then in 1971 we decided to unpeg the
dollar from gold
right so that's kind of the story of
gold but really dollars were just
a second or third layer to gold to make
it much easier to use gold
well that's what's happening with
bitcoin bitcoin chose to optimize for
one thing out of the gate and that was
the security
to provide store of value how does it
store the value
that you put into it and so today you
could think of bitcoin as a
so or a scientifically engineered
saving technology and what i mean by
that is by between the monetary policy
of that cap supply and the
disinflationary
monetary uh supply schedule combined
with
the fact that bitcoin is the strongest
computing network in the world meaning
nobody can hack it
that provides the trust or the
validation for people
to simply uh uh exchange their fiat
currency for bitcoin so they take
dollars they buy bitcoin they take euros
they buy bitcoin they take the r b they
buy bitcoin
and then they just hold it and the
reason why they're holding it is because
they believe
that the store of value it will protect
or preserve that purchasing power
and so compare that to the dollar right
the dollar basically is falling off a
cliff in terms of purchasing power year
over year 15 20
kind of degradation of that purchasing
power comparing that to bitcoin
bitcoin is basically going up 50 to 100
a year in terms of purchasing power and
so now you're starting to get people
waking up saying wait a second
if we know that currencies get adopted
by first being store of value then being
medium of exchanges
and bitcoin is first optimizing for
security and store of value and then is
now starting to add layers two and
three and you know into the future and
it's gonna become easier to transact
it's going to become
cheaper to transact actually again we're
just kind of on the natural progression
of adoption for a currency
so you overlay natural progression of
adoption for technology
with natural progression of adoption for
a currency
and you start to realize this bitcoin
thing is actually
really really interesting and it's
interesting because it is
so different than all of the other
currencies in the world
and i don't you know as an investor
you'll this will kind of hit home for
you right is
when everyone's doing the same thing
whether you know whatever the industry
is
and a new player comes along and says
i'm going to do something different
if that person's right they end up using
being incredibly disruptive to the
incumbents
yeah and so if you look around the world
at currencies every fiat currency is
exactly the same
they're all inflationary currencies
they're all governed by humans
usually with a central bank that's got a
small number of people who are making
decisions and they're manipulating
interest rates or quantitative easing
that's every currency they compete on
details right
who's got what interest rate who's
devaluing faster or slower but they're
all structurally the same
bitcoin comes along and says we have no
centralization we're completely
decentralized
we're gonna be programmatic we're gonna
be transparent and by the way we're
gonna have a cap supply therefore we're
gonna serve as a 180 degree different
choice than your fiat currencies
and so 12 years 600 billion dollars in
value
and i think we're on the way to
something much much higher into the
trillions of dollars
right if not tens of trillions of
dollars and it's simply because
this new challenger is a 180 degree
structural difference and people are
starting to understand the narrative
around
if i can find something that is more
accessible it's digital
i don't have to have a bank account i
can simply have an internet connection
and it is able to preserve my purchasing
power
in the us and canada that's interesting
right like yeah the dollar works for me
but like if i could preserve purchasing
power that's cool
in venezuela iran uh india
pakistan african countries that's life
or death that's literally the difference
between having money for food or not
and so i think that we forget you know
the u.s is 330 million people
we matter but we don't really matter
that much when you look at the seven
plus billion people in the world
that are beginning to look at this and
understand it uh and see where the
adoption is coming from
you're likely to see it with people who
understand hyperinflation you understand
the erosion of purchasing power
um and so that's what to me makes it so
interesting is as a global phenomenon
well but you but the americans do lead i
think one one of the things
two things that throw people like me off
is um
there haven't really been any new
currencies in a long time right so
all the countries have their currency
then a bunch of countries got together
and created the euro
so if anything there's a shrinking
number of currencies instead of an
expanding number of currencies
so bitcoin comes along and you and i
have been talking now for 52 minutes and
we only mentioned bitcoin
which for me is fine because i'm right
now so super like narrowly focused on
understanding bitcoin
if you throw ethereum into it and then a
number of others
do you think that the existence of
multiple um
currencies in crypto
is confusing to most people do you think
it's good for
the crypto economy or
is there really only room for one
reliable leading
currency and these are questions i have
no idea what the answer is
yeah so the framework i use to kind of
think through this and this is
uh you know just constantly iterating on
it talking to people from public
pensions endowments hospital systems
folks like yourself
all the way down to the average joe
literally on the street of new york
is i personally believe that every stock
bond currency and commodity will be
digitized in the future right what do
what does that mean it sounds cool but
what does that mean
if you go back kind of let's say pre-60s
70s and into the 80s
everything was analog literally there
was a physical stock certificate a
physical mortgage
you know a a physical deed to a home
whatever
and those were all transacted in the
analog world literally i would either
hand you or mail to you
a physical stock certificate and that
showed that you owned the shares in that
company
well the people who quickly realized
when the internet came out that i could
use a computer to now
purchase those same shares and i could
own an electronic q-sip versus owning
the physical paper
they had a significant advantage they
were early adopters right and now all of
a sudden
i could buy and sell with information
asymmetry with
trade execution advantages whatever well
every
asset now is that electronic q sip it's
kind of the electronic age of these
securities
so literally you can own a mortgage as
an electronic q sub you can own a stock
a currency all that kind of stuff like
when you say you have multiple
currencies in your portfolio
you don't literally have the physical
currency sitting in you know
a safe somewhere you own them through
these electronic q-sips
now what's happening is we're moving
from that electronic version to this
digital version
right and so in that world you're going
to have digital stocks digital bonds
digital currencies digital commodities
in the world of crypto there are a very
very small number of
assets that are trying to be digital
currencies right bitcoin is one of them
uh there's these things called stable
coins which are basically backed one to
one to fiat currencies
uh central banks are talking about
creating central bank digital currencies
um but but a currency very specifically
as a store-value medium of exchange
uh has kind of a definition to it and
there's very few in there bitcoin by far
being the leader
there is a whole host of other things
trying to be digital uh
stocks bonds and commodities so
something like ether which is part of
the ethereum system right
is not so much trying to be a currency
right people aren't trying to use it
uh simply as a currency it's more
something akin to
a digital commodity right it's used to
power the system it's used to gain
access to things
um and so there are some applications
that are that want to use ether as money
um i've got my personal opinion as to
why i don't think that's going to happen
but if you talk to the folks in the
ethereum community they say look this is
something different bitcoin and ethereum
don't compete with each other they're
complementary
right they empower different things
their purposes are different
and so that nuance just understanding
bitcoin and ether are
built for two different things once you
understand it you're like oh okay that
makes sense to me
the problem is that majority of people
outside of crypto have
no clue that that's true right they just
think of oh they're all digital assets
and like they're all competing for each
other
and why is number one number one versus
number eight thousand number eight
thousand
there's just a miscommunication so what
i think the world we're moving to and
the part that becomes really interesting
is
your portfolio eventually you're gonna
hold not just your stocks next to other
stocks
you're going to hold every stock bond
currency and commodity in one
single digital wallet and the switching
cost between those assets is going to go
way down
so today if you want to go from owning a
stock uh to
then owning let's say uh you want to
pick a really obscure fiat currency
you probably have to sell your stock
into either canadian or u.s dollars then
you got to go do the currency exchange
right
and it's a pain in the ass frankly even
more so is if you want to take
the currency that you got paid at you
know salary for a job
and then go buy a stock you got to get
paid into your bank account you then got
to wire it into your brokerage you kind
of got to go buy the stock all that kind
of stuff
well when everything just sits in the
same place and has some level of
um kind of compatibility on a technology
layer your ability to go from
getting paid in uh us dollars into the r
b
then into bitcoin then into a stock then
into a bond
that friction goes down we enter this
really interesting world where people
start to say wait a second
why do i hold so much cash or why do i
hold so many equities right
the friction that the switching cost
goes down
and so what i ultimately believe is
going to happen is bitcoin will continue
to rise it'll continue to be this great
store of value on a global basis
it'll serve as not only a global reserve
currency but it'll serve as a personal
or corporate
reserve currency what i mean by that is
the government in the us may never
accept bitcoin
for taxes let's say they may just say we
only accept us dollars great
you're gonna get paid in us dollars with
a click of a button you'll be able to
either automatically or manually switch
that dollar into bitcoin you'll sit
there and hold it it'll preserve your
purchasing power
until you're ready to spend it and then
when you want to spend it you'll click
back into the u.s dollar and you go pay
your taxes or buy something at the store
or whatever
that'll persist for some period of time
but eventually if bitcoin just becomes
stable because
so many people have it there's so much
liquidity
all of a sudden you start to say wait a
second why can't i just use this asset
right and i think that's the world that
bitcoiners see you know i don't know if
it's
15 years out or 100 years out but that's
the world that i think a lot of
bitcoiners are saying wait a second
this is how this currency is going to
evolve over time yeah i think the
volatility actually
hurts its ability to be a transactional
currency because if it's
going up tripled in the last eight weeks
um
very few currencies uh do that some
currencies fall by that
percentage but very few robots but so my
last question
is is i told you a story earlier where a
regulatory event
led me to a decision to turn off and
erode
eight billion dollars of market cap
value of a very widely held
ftse 100 stock on the london stock
exchange uh so
there is talk about regulatory risk in
crypto
um how do you address sort of you know
people saying well it's going to be
regulated well the governments will
control it the central banks will
control it the people like roubini
and people we trust or like or respect
um
whose books we read um are i don't know
if they're naysayers
some of them are naysayers some of them
are cynics so maybe it's a two-part
question
one is credible cynics and the other is
regulatory risk
yeah so i think that one uh having the
regulatory conversation is important
right people who just completely ignored
or deflect it
uh aren't being realistic like there is
regulation in the world right and
the beauty of regulation for the
regulators is that they have armed men
that will come put you in jail if you
don't listen
right so like that is a very real um
kind of conversation to have
now the first part is like where are we
with regulation so
the in the united states specifically
the sec and cftc have both come out and
they've said look bitcoin is not a
security
right so this is a property or currency
it's something else other than
uh kind of a regulated security like
you'd see on a stock exchange that's
important because it
allows for more people to hold it and do
other things with it that you can't do
with a stock
the second thing is that every company
that transacts with
or is related or interacts with bitcoin
has to be a regulated entity based on
existing rules so they haven't created
new rules in most cases there might be a
state here or there that's created new
rules but for the most part
if you want to transmit money right be a
money transmitter you have to get a
money transmission license
in the states you want to interact with
so you're kind of held to or regulated
by the same exact rules you would be
whether it was us dollars or it is
bitcoin
now that could change that's one of the
big concerns is all of a sudden there's
more regulation on bitcoin or crypto
companies we'll see if that happens or
not
there's a lot of people working on the
non-profit and lobbying side to kind of
prevent that from happening a lot of
education with
elected leaders but but that's one part
of the conversation the second
part and i think the thing that scares
people more is not so much
hey are these companies going to be
regulated or is there going to be kyc
aml right is there basically going to be
like feature parity to my
my legacy institution it's is the
government going to step in and
ban ownership right are they going to
try to do something that would be
catastrophic from an ownership
perspective
am i as a holder of bitcoin going to be
at risk in some way
and the key part about bitcoin that i
think is so interesting
is just like the regulators pulled you
know jack dorsey mark zuckerberg
uh jeff bezos whoever into these
regulatory hearings and they said
you're the ceo you're going to be in
trouble if you don't do x or y or z
or we're going to shut down your servers
or we're going to come you know and
uh and come to your offices none of that
exists with bitcoin there's no ceo to
call in front of regulators there's no
headquarters to go to there's no one to
put in jail or fine
or go shut down and so that
decentralization
actually becomes an incredibly
advantageous position to be in
given what bitcoin is becoming but what
the u.s could do is say
we are going to ban ownership of anyone
in the united states with gold they
confiscated gold they made it illegal to
own back in the 30s
and so they could attempt to do that the
difference though is i think that we
would see an
absolute global like scavenger hunt
of all of these governments saying the
united states is going to not adopt this
let's get off the u.s dollar system
let's all go and adopt it right if
russia china you know whatever other
major superpower we want to get off the
us dollar system we think that it is
expensive
we think that it is risky because they
can sanction us and tariffs and all this
kind of stuff
let's get off and so i think that
there's enough people in the government
who are saying
an outright ban is probably an overreach
that's probably not good for the
sustainability and the position of power
and influence the united states wants to
have
but we should add more regulation we
should have kyc aml we should have
companies that have to
you know become uh broker dealers or
bank licensed or whatever it is
i think that's good i think that's good
by the way it's good for the currency
because that means my mom can write
bitcoin more easily
you know it's it's true you know my mom
was buying cisco
which is how i knew that in 2000 the
bubble was there because you didn't know
what
she thought system made oil cooking oil
and i thought that was crystal but
and it's true story but the reality
is that you want that if it's aml kyc
and
your broker or your online broker is is
uh
is able to to transact in it then it
gets actually it's actually a good thing
[Music]
yeah look i i think that those folks are
um
either one uneducated uh or two they're
actually very educated
and uh they're playing the role of
entertainer right and there's a whole
spectrum
a spectrum of them uh i tend to say to
myself
um that's how a market is made like you
need the people who don't believe
because that's where the market is
um and frankly when you talk to
most people uh or almost everybody i
don't think i've met a single person who
did the work to educate themselves and
be able to talk intelligently about
bitcoin
who didn't say yeah there's a good
chance this works right maybe they're
not a full-on bitcoiner maybe they've
got some concerns or questions
but nobody walks away and says this is
really stupid i can't believe anyone
believes in it
uh and it's going to zero right and so i
think education and time spent is really
important it's kind of the investment
you make to get to that place
the second thing is uh i don't know a
bitcoiner
who isn't praying the price goes down
this is really interesting
every stock per you know uh kind of
investor they want the price to go up
bitcoiners have this deep-seated
long-term belief that the
the us dollar value is going to continue
to rise they actually want the price to
go down in the short term though so they
can get more of it
they always kind of feel like i don't
own enough i don't own enough and so
that is a really interesting
psychological element because i
maybe it happens in some stocks you know
like a tesla or something like that
but that doesn't really happen to the
degree you see in bitcoin
and so it's almost the exact opposite
level of
uh fervor than the cynics right like
like the critics of bitcoin
are super passionate they go on
television they make a bunch of noise uh
and they kind of you know get a bunch of
clicks and attention for it
well the bitcoiners are almost exactly
you know the opposite
but just as passionate they go on
television they say a bunch of crazy
stuff people all pay attention whatever
and so you get this really interesting
asset where you've got
two sides they've dug their heels in and
the market's going to be the referee the
market's going to determine who's right
and who's wrong and you know
i'm bi i mentioned a couple of times
because
um you know he's a clear bull super
smart
guy that i know and respect a lot um a
lot of the poker community
uh very very smart very well educated on
on
on bitcoin it does take uh it does take
naysayers but i
want to mention one more thing which is
that you're not my financial advisor
you're becoming a friend and i respect
you a lot you your comment to me
privately was mitch
you should put two percent of your net
worth in bitcoin and that makes perfect
sense
right that means that ninety percent of
your assets are not even
um and i think it was you or chamoth who
tweeted
that you know the the most difficult
bitcoin to buy is your first and once
you own it you don't own enough of it
might have been both of you
tweeting to each other but so i still
don't own my first but it sounds like it
makes sense like once you own it you
want
more of it and the most difficult
barrier to jump over is the initial one
to get the first bitcoin
so uh i'll leave you with this you'll
appreciate it and then
we'll go into some rapid fire questions
to end up but uh i used to tell people
by one percent
and somebody who i won't name uh who's
pretty well known in the finance world
said
that's not fun because if it goes down
fifty percent i only lost 50 basis
points
so then i started to say two percent
because if it goes down 50 then you've
at least lost a whole one percent of
your uh
of your portfolio and then you can
really feel like you know there was some
pain there
um but uh no i i i think that's the
right way to think about it right it's
like just once you kind of
breach the the wall a little bit you say
all right i'm gonna buy one or i'm gonna
buy you know with half a percent one
percent
very quickly people get up to speed so
um all right before i let you go i've
got three questions
uh that i ask everyone first one is
what's the most important book that
you've ever read
the most important book that i've read
is startup nation um i'm half israeli
uh i speak hebrew i lived in israel i
bought and sold israeli companies
and it's actually not that the book
taught me a lot it's that
the book is a great source of pride that
the rest of the world gets to read it
um and see what israel is all about
especially since there are
many misperceptions um it's not a
perfect country but it's a great country
and it's i think you know the second
greatest entrepreneurial counsel in the
world i think america is the greatest
entrepreneurial country
in uh in the world so that's really the
most important book that uh that i've
read for that reason
yeah that's a fantastic answer no one's
ever said that one before uh the second
question
uh is a question that is sponsored by
eight sleep so
uh mateo who's the ceo there uh has
absolutely berated me into becoming a
better sleeper
i sleep on this mattress that they have
that cools it off and i told him i would
now ask everybody
what is the sleep routine like do you
get four hours of sleep eight hours of
sleep
how important is it and do you actually
focus on sleep
or uh is it something that just kind of
you do with the bare
necessity so it's a super it's a bit of
a personal question
for me because um i also i'm very
transparent in every
i do a lot of interviews and i say ask
me any question i'll answer it so i
sleep extremely poorly
uh i wake up a couple times in the night
i rarely sleep
five hours more than five hours i take
sleeping pills two
three four times a week just to take an
edge off to hopefully fall asleep
um i i could use help i've never sought
help like
some type of sleep therapy somehow uh so
your friend
i'll speak to anyone because i'm a
horrible sleeper i've been functional
i have a lot of energy it hasn't hurt me
um
i hope it hasn't taken any years off my
life but i'm i'm not a good sleeper
uh i will introduce you to mateo he he
will you're like his uh his perfect
person
for people who for sleep uh sleep
research
last year i took 120 flights and not
only did i not sleep very well because
of that but i was always sleeping in
like on a plane or you know on a red-eye
or whatever
and uh when i met him and and he started
getting me up the uh the curve i gotta
say it was like the most impactful thing
and you forget like what a good night's
sleep is so
um it's just interesting to hear from
people uh last question
and then uh we will cut it is aliens are
you a believer or a non-believer
non-believer not now why yeah
um listen could there be life out there
there could be
can i explain you know other than
through you know big bang theories and
darwinism
our existence no i'm not that smart um
but and i don't need to i don't need to
have real hard evidence of something to
believe in it
but um you know i i've it's never
occurred to me that there are aliens
um you know where there's some other
life form but the galaxies are so huge
that the possibility that there's other
life forms in some galaxy are probably
very high i don't know if that's what's
called aliens
um when you get into aliens that have
maybe visited earth and i don't believe
at all
ufos don't believe it all um you know
maybe i'm
i maybe i'm too much of a cartesian uh
cartesian thinker
for galaxies is one thing i agree with
more star trek more star trek style than
um
i need to thank my son ryan for
introducing us because this
this generational you know that would
never happen in in the old days
you know i could never have introduced
my father
you know when i was 20 to someone in
business that he needed to know
um the internet and twitter and tick
tock and instagram
it's amazing um and it's what brought us
together and i
owe him a great debt of gratitude yeah
he uh one is super smart obviously and
uh
the thing i think that i'm most
impressed by and hopefully i'm not
revealing too much here
is uh when we've talked uh you've had
them on the call
and they're not only intelligent uh
they're intellectually curious like you
are
um and it's very fascinating to me to
see kind of
you bring certain skills and experience
and interest they bring
different ones in some cases and you
guys are able to kind of meld those
together and so
you know kudos one to you to kind of
having them involved but also to
uh to uh for for them to be interested
enough to pay attention as well
and also thanks for showing them
interest and giving them the time i
appreciate it
of course how can people find you on the
internet where should we send them
yeah mitch garber on twitter i speak a
lot in french but that's okay i
shouldn't turn you off
um yeah miss barbara on twitter i'm
mitch barber on instagram
uh mitch at mitchfarberinvestments.com
you can find me
come on subscriber
every time i see you tweeting about
bitcoin it's usually you're tweeting at
me telling me hey man stop
stop rubbing it in that it's going down
and when i see me
but i won't so it's okay when i see you
tweeting in french i'm like oh he's
definitely talking bad about us
no i love you guys thank you absolutely
thanks so much for doing this mitch
okay